Es el segundo país más poblado de la tierra,
la séptima mayor economía, uno de los 10
estados con mayor presupuesto militar y uno
de los pocos con armas nucleares A pesar de
ello, la India es en términos políticos
un país prácticamente desconocido.
En un vídeo anterior, mi compañero Fonseca
os preguntaba por el nombre del Presidente
de China, pues bien, yo en este vídeo os
hago una pregunta similar ¿Cuál es el nombre
del Primer Ministro de la India?
Sé que muchos lo sabéis, si no es así,
no os preocupéis, no es extraño
El 26 de mayo de 2014, tras obtener una mayoría
absoluta inédita en 30 años, Narendra Modi
se convirtió en el Primer Ministro de la
India.
¿Su misión? Era clara: impulsar el crecimiento,
la inversión y crear millones empleos.
En definitiva, convertir a la India en una superpotencia
capaz de competir con China a nivel económico,
militar y político.
Porque la India es, amigos de VisualPolitik, algo así como
la eterna promesa, el país que siempre parece
va a despegar, pero que al final se queda
en tierra.
De hecho, basta con fijarse en cómo han evolucionado
los PIB de China y la India en las últimas
décadas.
Pues bien, con la victoria de Modi, las expectativas
se volvieron a disparar, y hoy la India vuelve
a estar de moda.
El propio Modi no se cansa de repetir que
el s.XXI será el siglo de la India.
Pero… antes que nada
Vegetariano, soltero y practicante de Yoga,
Modi es un político que escapa al perfil
convencional. Procede de una familia humilde,
y de niño ayudaba a su padre a vender té
en una estación de tren.
Esto es algo que le ha hecho ganarse la simpatía
de muchas personas pobres del país, que ven
en él una muestra de que el ascensor social
a veces funciona.
¡Modi!¡Modi!¡Modi!
Su pensamiento político siempre ha estado
muy ligado al hinduismo, aunque, no siempre
bajo planteamientos moderados, de hecho, antes
de militar en el BJP lo hizo en el RSS, un
partido de extrema derecha del que formó
también parte Nathuram Godse, el asesino
del Mahatma Gandhi.
Bien, durante 13 años, entre 2001 y 2014,
Modi fue el Primer Ministro Regional del Estado
de Gujarat, que, con 65 millones de habitantes,
se convirtió, bajo su dirección, en la locomotora
de la India, logrando un crecimiento anual
medio durante su mandato de más del 10% anual.
Y, claro junto a ello, también mejoraron
todos los parámetros de bienestar social,
Prácticamente todos los hogares lograron
acceder a servicios de agua, electricidad
y educación infantil.
Precisamente, durante la campaña de las elecciones
generales Modi prometió replicar en la India
el éxito de Gujaret.
Y prometió hacerlo, además, en apenas 10
años, en dos mandatos.
Porque para Modi, 2022 es el año clave: se
celebrará el 75 aniversario de la independencia
de la India; el país superará a China como
el más poblado, con más de 1.600 millones
de habitantes,
y, según Modi, quedará claro que este es
el siglo de la India.
Pero no será fácil, la India, un país cuya
población crece, ojo, al ritmo de 28 habitantes
cada minuto, es compleja.
Son muchos los problemas de este país, pero
podemos destacar tres:
1 – Su enorme burocracia. La India, amigos,
es el paraíso de la burocracia. De hecho,
si esta fuese la clave de la prosperidad,
la India probablemente sería el país más
rico del mundo. Desgraciadamente, la burocracia,
en vez de alentar los negocios, acaba con
ellos.
.
Según el informe Doing Business del Banco
Mundial, que mide la facilidad para hacer
negocios, la India ocupa el puesto 130.
En este país cada trámite requiere de montones
de papeles y los impuestos, además, de ser
altos – aunque pocos los pagan, hay que
decirlo – son un infierno.
Por ejemplo, no es que existan impuestos diferentes
en cada estado, no, es que muchas veces los impuestos
son diferentes para cada producto y en algunos
casos, para cada modelo de un mismo producto,
como ocurre con los automóviles. Una locura.
Además, el absentismo entre los funcionarios
es tan alto que se han reportado casos de
hospitales cerrados porque los funcionarios
no iban a trabajar. ¡Aquí al menos llegan tarde!
- "¿Es usted funcionaria? - eee Sí - Y ¿Cuál es su horario laboral? ¿Cuál es su hora de entrar? -Me abstengo de decirlo - Ahora son las 08:45 - Bueno, yo es que hoy me he dormido.
2 – Como consecuencia de las complejas regulaciones,
la ruptura del mercado es casi total.
En los pasos fronterizos, entre los diferentes estados
que componen el país, los camiones de mercancías
se acumulan en colas interminables; y no son
pocos los que dicen que es más fácil importar
que comprar en el interior del país.
Tampoco ayuda el estado ruinoso de las infraestructuras
públicas.
Pues bien, se calcula que la mitad de las
cosechas se pierden antes siquiera de llegar
a los mercados.
3 – La corrupción es una lacra muy extendida
por toda la sociedad. Por ejemplo, el 50%
de todas las ayudas entregadas por el gobierno
a familias y personas pobres, se quedan en
manos de intermediarios y políticos corruptos.
Este es el país al que se está enfrentando
Modi.
Aunque no haya llevado a cabo la revolución
que algunos planteaban, la verdad es que el
nuevo gobierno ha realizado en poco tiempo
avances muy destacados.
Entre las apuestas del gobierno indio podemos
destacar las siguientes:
- Para reducir la burocracia, el gobierno
ha formado una comisión que tiene como meta
determinar que leyes y normativas están obsoletas
y deben ser eliminadas. Llevan más de 1.700.
- Modi ha suprimido muchas restricciones a
la inversión extranjera, ha aprobado la primera
ley de quiebras y ha puesto en marcha un potente
programa para promocionar a la India como
destino
para empresas.
- "India se ha convertido en una gran oportunidad de inversión para empresas extranjeras. Casi una 60% de su PIB procede de consumo interno."
- Se ha impulsado un programa muy ambicioso
para lograr una mayor inclusión financiera.
El programa que tiene este nombre que veis,
impronunciable, ya ha logrado que más de
200 millones de personas tengan por primera
vez una cuenta bancaria. De esta forma, por
ejemplo, las subvenciones ya no pasarán por
intermediarios.
- El gobierno está liderando la implantación
de un impuesto único sobre las ventas a nivel
nacional, que tiene que terminar con el caos
del actual sistema impositivo.
- Modi ha anunciado una importante inversión
en infraestructura. Tan solo en la red ferroviaria,
130.000 millones de dólares hasta 2020.
- "El Gobierno indio quiere atraer a más inversores internacionales, entre otras cosas para modernizar la deteriorada infraestructura.
Sin buenas carreteras ni puertos, la economía no avanza."
Con todo, su medida más polémica y más
arriesgada llegó en noviembre de 2016
Para luchar contra la corrupción y el dinero
negro, el gobierno ilegalizo a principios
de noviembre de 2016 los billetes de 500 y
1000 rupias, que representaban más del 85%
del efectivo de un país en el que casi todos
los pagos se hacen con cash.
La medida tenía como objetivo lograr cazar
el dinero negro y penalizarlo cuando sus dueños
fuesen a cambiarlo por los nuevos billetes.
Pues bien, el plan ha sido un total desastre:
el gobierno no tenía suficientes billetes
nuevos para sustituir los viejos y los cajeros
ni siquiera estaban adaptados porque los nuevos
billetes tienen tamaños distintos.
Una chapuza que ha dejado al país sin dinero,
ocasionándole un gran daño a la actividad económica.
- "¿Qué están haciendo? Estamos angustiados, hoy no comimos nada. Espero conseguir pronto dinero".
Las ventas se hundieron en noviembre más
de un 30%, muchos centros de trabajo no han
podido pagar a sus trabajadores y muchísimas
operaciones se han cancelado.
Algunos estudios cifran ya el daño en al
menos 2 puntos del PIB. Es decir, al país
le puede costar esta chapuza casi 50.000 millones
de dólares. Por supuesto, los más perjudicados,
una vez más, han sido los más pobres.
Este es el campo donde más ha destacado el
nuevo Primer Ministro indio.
Tan solo en su primer año visito 19 países
y a pesar del poco tiempo transcurrido ya ha conseguido avances: el trato con Pakistan
ha registrado síntomas de mejora y la relación
con China parece que comienza a canalizarse
hacia la vertiente económica y comercial.
Aunque, sin duda alguna, el punto fuerte de
la agenda, ha sido su acercamiento a los EEUU.
De hecho, ha sido muy significativa la buena
conexión entre Obama y Modi, sus encuentros
han sido frecuentes y muy amistosos. Ambos
escribieron, por cierto, un artículo conjunto
en el Washington Post que fue toda una declaración
de intenciones.
La pregunta ahora es ¿Conseguirá Modi sus
objetivos? A priori parece difícil, porque
si algo está demostrado es que es muy complicado
limitar la burocracia allí donde ha cobrado
mucho peso, y aquí la India se lleva la palma.
Por otro lado, Modi ha guardado en el cajón
muchas reformas imprescindibles, como, por
ejemplo, poner fin a una regulación laboral
que ocasiona que cuatro quintas partes de
los trabajos sean informales.
Modi afirma ser un admirador de Lee Kuan Yew,
el expresidente de Singapur, pero no está
claro que tenga la misma determinación para
transformar el ruinoso modelo de la India.
Espero que te haya gustado el vídeo, si ha
sido así no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik,
pinchando en este botón.
Por cierto, desde aquí le queremos dar las
gracias a Alejandro Estebaranz, del canal
El Arte de Invertir, por la ayuda que nos
ha prestado para hacer este vídeo.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.